that time of year when animals you know
it's wintertime for animals and a lot of
animals you know you won't see them
they're hibernate you know even though
they got I saw some animals say this
lady had two little bitty dogs and let
me tell you this lady's some of you
ladies with these little bitty dogs what
the you doing because some of these
aren't dogs okay
some of these are little it's just your
insecurities with four legs that's all
it is some of these are a little figment
of your imagination that you're that you
are a buying from who knows where that
mother nature's creating a
mother nature never created some of
these little fake-ass animals I remember
I was alive in 1992 half these dogs
didn't exist they look like a little
cold reindeer what are some of
these animals here's my thing if a
frisbee will kill it is it a dog that's
where I draw that line because I see
some of these ladies just walking these
things that are not they're not even
they all have emphysema and they all
have you know brain surgery and they're
wearing colostomy bags and because
they're they're not real they weigh
three pounds that's not a animal
that's a science experiment and it's
just some of it you you see that you see
the dog and you're like just something
wrong with this thing it can't breathe
its eyes coming a separate carrying case
home that they wear on it back and you
got to pull out and put them in its head
I mean it's some of these dog it's not
even real they can't eat anything they
have two sips of water it's just it's
just scary some of it's not real and so
as much as we're you know people are
trying to rescue animals in this kind of
having these fake animals is just
that's scary
it's very scary man thank you guys for
checking out this clip and if you want
to see another clip then you can look at
this clip or this clip either one of
these so did you pick one or he's still
just watching me do this because this is
alarming